let's see if we can factor the
expression 45
x squared
minus 1
25.
so whenever i see something like this i
have a second degree term here i have a
i have a subtraction sign
my attention my temptations is to look
at this as a difference of squares we've
already seen this multiple times we've
already seen that if we have something
of the form if we have something of the
form a squared minus b squared that this
can be factored as a plus b
times a minus b
so let's look over here well over here
it's not obvious that this right over
here is a perfect square neither is it
obvious that this right over here is a
perfect square so it's not clear to me
that this is a difference of squares but
what is interesting is that both 45 and
125 have have some factors in common and
the one that jumps out at me is five so
let's see if we can factor out a five
and by doing that whether we can get
something that's a little bit closer to
this pattern right over here so if we
factor out a 5 this becomes 5
times
5 times well 45 x squared divided by 5
is going to be 9 x squared and then 125
divided by 5 is 25
is 25. now this is interesting 9x
squared that's a perfect square
if we call this if we call this a
squared then that tells us that a
would be equal to 3x 3x the whole thing
squared is 9x squared
similarly i can never say similarly or
correctly
25 is clearly just 5 squared so in this
case if we're looking at if we're
looking at this template b would be
equal to 5. so now this is a difference
of squares and we can factor it
completely so we can't forget our 5 out
front that we factored out so it's going
to be 5 times
a plus b so let me write this so it's
going to be 5 times a plus b
times 5 times a minus b
so it's 5 times a plus b
times a minus b so let me write the b's
down plus b
and
minus b
and we're done 5 times 3x plus 5 times
3x minus 5 is 45x squared minus 125
factored out